nilan chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
voici juku tôt j'en ai glisse à fontaine
ses colonnades bars au couteau paisible
vous
immobile
on le retrouve comme dans chaque coin du
monde le même geste agglomérée sur ce
cadran solaire des gosses jouent
accroché semble-t-il autant est
cependant en optyl la notion
seuls les besognes la leur donne
peut-être c'est probablement le pays où
la femme est le plus besogneux auchan
devant son métier sur les marchés le
dernier né sur son dos la femme indienne
déploie une activité sans relâche et
lorsqu'elle a une minute de détente
l'emploi a filé des laine multicolore
moi à lui est jamais là bas les pommes
de terre ne sont jamais plus grosse
qu'une prunes quant aux outils modernes
ou n'ont pas encore atteint ses
habitudes touch fait à la main l'âne et
le boeuf restent les seuls moyens de
transport le labeur mais vu leur pas
toujours frugal il est fait le plus
souvent de pommes de terre cuites sous
la cendre
pour ce qui est assez voisin de la
misère
scène journalières ou le lama joue un
grand rôle
il est partout le lamarre
partout on retrouve aussi des traces des
jésuites de la conquête
voici ce qui reste de leur passage dans
la petite bourgade de dookie
et la vie se poursuit quotidienne
courageux
on
et pour qu'elle se poursuive vraiment il
faut aussi des embarcations les balsa
les barques du lac titicaca fait de tora
hautes herbes qui croisent sur les bords
coupé séché très hachée plusieurs notes
font de gros rouleaux et ligoté ensemble
ils forment la pirogue la vie de ces
pirogues dure à peu près une année puis
pourrissante elles s'en vont à la dérive
et il faudra trois jours à l'homme pour
reconstruire une nouvelle péronne
c'est un travail de patience et adresse
c'est très joli vérone
c'est les juifs ça va relativement envie
de pêcher maniable
adieu sans au revoir
et nous traversons ce lac qui est le
miroir le plus haut du monde avant de
passer en bolivie
l'air est ultra les jours parfois la
respiration vient à manquer alors le
coeur sa foi mais en compensation la
luminosité est intense
paumé village copacabana rien de commun
avec la plage mondaine du brésil n'ont
vraiment rien de commun une très
ancienne vièle indienne la vierge noire
fait de cet endroit a lieu de pèlerinage
suivons ses lamas à travers les ruines
de tuân nat cole ou les ruines incas ah
bon
l'altiplano se brise brusquement en une
coupure m
voici la partie appelée royal des andes
dans les lits made me dresse fièrement
ses 6500 mètres tout au fond chapeautée
de blanc
la base sa ville qui devrait puisque la
plus haute du globe être fiers
m'empêcher chercher sur un roc et
encerclé comme prisonnière dans une
mâchoire de rochers il se dresse comme
des châteaux de légende
la plupart des deux ponts porté par ces
populations sont à base d'or et d'argent
là encore la respecte le rapporte au
cours des derniers siècles son influence
néanmoins des styles pelvien evo libyens
restent caractéristiques
voici un bâton de chefs caciques
surmonté de pièces de monnaie et
incrustée de pierres
c'est l'emblème que portent les alcade
et qui désignent leurs fonctions
le poisson à droite et signe de
prospérité
et voici servi en broche ou grandeur
nature aux écailles articuler des
poissons
fait curieux ils sont devenus
actuellement fantaisie de nos bijoux
tient à la mode
céramique terre cuite
de possibles
pl zep en brûle parfum servant aux
cérémonies et au sacrifice
cette pierre en étoile est une machine
chef guerrier servant de casse tête
elle rappelle curieusement les
morgenstein suisse d'où vient que sur
tous ces objets plane encore l'ombre du
fétichisme c'est qu'ils ont sans doute
gardé en eux le souvenir de
l'accomplissement de série des indiens
mélange de croyance
d'adoration de superstition tour à tour
l'esprit payen l'esprit divin l'esprit
malin
esprit vous qui commande vous tous qui
obéissent et venez venez à l'appel de
votre chef esprit répondait ciel inca
soleil divinités païennes invocations
sorcery esprit vous qui commande et vous
tous qui n'obéissait c'est moi qui vous
appelle venez venez à l'appel de votre
chef
répondez sans tarder répondait aussi peu
j'enverrai le vent il attend des gens
vers l orage qui tombe de la nuée
j'enverrai l'éclair qui passe enfants
dans le ciel j'enverrai le tonnerre qui
passe en prison tout
vous tous qui mobilise ses esprits
répondez
on
mais quatre
yann chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de solange beyter
montage michel la touche son annick v10
script nathalie de muret illustration
sonore denise glaser
non